do you know what makes a real hero it's  not the costumes the gadgets the cool  powers it's having your own movie and  that has always been my dream  what are you doing just giving the  people at the wall our movies not about  Wonder Woman it's about us the Teen  Titan Noah wants to see us full Wonder  Woman inspires people and we do not yes  Wonder Woman is great but I love Wonder  Woman narrator guy just do your thing  when the creators of Teen Titans go  it's a balance of courage it's about  action  it's the superhero movie to end all  superhero movies  hopefully that wasn't a fart that was  just air leaving my butt which is a fart  Teen Titans go to the movies because if  Aquaman can get a movie anyone can  you